pay attention to micros and top figure
because you want to know what to expect
when you try this food you can
I don't like the mere truth that
I have a homemade taste
good it's no joke it doesn't know anything it's
an American version but it tastes good
diaz another  You see
well
in Mexico the days in the rites
and a lot it
does not convince me with a very good one but not
I better a way to fifth
but it is that you see something different in the
tortilla in it
something good
yes
it is not good it is very salty very dry it
does not have  nothing tactful
for us it is an anniversary that I
would ask for an omelette just with
cream instead
and that the caps give me a lot of flavor
and this is not something that you would
invent at home a question
within a fat boy I did not know but
The best thing I couldn't describe was what I
just tried because it's not Mexican food with a
lot of different flavor.
to return